diesen Döner macht etwas Besonders ich
habe ihn selbst gemacht in meiner Küche
ihr seht alles im Hintergrund wie wir
das gemacht haben seht ihr im heutigen
Video und wir haben einen Ehrengast
volle der das Ding heute bewertet also
eins kann ich sagen ich habe Schmerzen
davor jetzt schon falls der scheiße
schmeckt so denn doof zu bewerten aber
wir müssen ehrlich sein Max das seid ihr
jetzt schon mal viel passiert viel
Arbeit war nötig fangen wir an mit der
Planung Holle schön dass Du den Moment
Zeit nimmst für uns ich möchte zum
ersten Mal selbst einen Döner machen und
wer sollte mir sagen was ein Döner
ausmacht wenn ich du was macht für dich
einen guten Döner aus
[Musik]
geile geiles Fundament sein Okay Fleisch
ist das A&O was ist für dich die beste
Auswahl die man treffen kann es gibt ja
kein Hähnchen oder auch Rind so ich weiß
du bist auch großer Fan von Fair hat ne
zum Beispiel
[Musik]
das ist einfach studiert du hast einfach
Döner studiert du bist Doktor in Döner
einlegen ein bis zwei Tage nach zwei
Wochen lang und ja alter Schwede ohne
Witz das ist zu krank ne du bist
wirklich
selbst gebacken ne da müssen wir nicht
drüber reden
vielen Dank die Rolle wir sehen uns ja
ich melde mich geil Alter hau rein ciao
ciao tschüss
alter Schwede da haben wir doch
tatsächlich mit dem echten Doktor Oehler
gesprochen also was Holle alles über
Döner weiß da kann man wirklich nur sein
Hut vorziehen mache ich aber nicht wenn
man Frisur verkackt ist ja Leute wir
wissen jetzt was wir brauchen ich würde
sagen machen uns dann einkaufen
marinieren spieß-stecken Brot backen wir
haben einiges zu tun jetzt weiß ich
schon mal was einen guten Döner ausmacht
hoffentlich kriegen wir auch einen hin
das schaffen wir auf jeden Fall
wow leute das ist eine Menge Fleisch wir
waren extra eine Metzger der darauf
spezialisiert ist Dönerspieße zu machen
und haben uns aus kalt und Rind eine
Mischung zusammengestellt was hier vorne
seht sind Zutaten für die Marinade die
kommt nicht von irgendwem sondern vom
König des Döners fern hat er ist einfach
verrate ich euch natürlich nicht die
genauen Mengenangaben und mögliche
geheimen Zutaten wir haben Zwiebeln
Joghurt und Salz weil wir wie bei
Pferden die Qualität vom Fleisch
scheinen lassen wollen wir nehmen uns
hier so ein food Prozessor und da die
Zwiebeln rein und Hexen die einfach
schön klein zu einer Paste probieren wir
das jetzt zu unserem Joghurt wenn das
ganze verrührt ist und möglicherweise
noch die ein oder andere Geheimzutat
drin ist ist unsere Marinade auch schon
fertig gehen jetzt mit unserer Marinade
dran einfach ordentlich drüber wir
mischen durch so dass wirklich alle
Seiten davon gleichmäßig bedeckt sind
dann wird es abgedeckt und mariniert für
einen ganzen Tag so sieht das Ganze aus
wenn es fertig ist Leute es riecht schon
ein bisschen nach Döner hier in der Luft
man sieht alles ist gleichmäßig bedeckt
die Marinade hat jetzt richtig viel Zeit
einzuziehen langsam werde ich
zuversichtlich dass zumindest der Spieß
etwas werden könnte ich habe richtig
Angst vom Schneiden und vor vielen
anderen Komponenten deshalb machen wir
direkt weiter das ist eine Miniatur
dönermaschine und wir packen das Ding
jetzt mal aus
hier sieht der JBL
leute das ist wirklich ein kleiner Traum
ich merke das gerade erst wo das so vor
mir steht ich wollte schon immer mal
selbst Döner machen und jetzt so ein
Spielzeug zu haben einfach nice so
Freunde es wird Zeit für den Teig für
die Brote denn natürlich machen wir sie
selbst zumindest 8 Stunden danach kaufen
ehrlich ich bin ehrgeizig ich will ins
Ranking das wäre so dumm es wäre so
krank wenn ich jetzt kommen würde wir
haben hier 600 ml Milch dazu gebe ich
frische Hefe Brösel die so ein bisschen
rein in Würfeln ja ich zwei Kilometer
die gebe ich einmal in unsere
Rührschüssel dazu zwei Teelöffel Zucker
und zwei Teelöffel Salz das ganze schon
mal durchrühren damit sich die trockenen
Zutaten verbinden und jetzt Hefe und
Milch dazugeben das sieht gut aus das
sieht super aus und das ganze verkneten
wie jetzt glatt wichtig ist dass man
schön durchknetet dass das Ganze Mehl
mit Feuchtigkeit versorgt wird und sich
diese schöne Gluten strukturiert unser
Teig Tornado ist fertig verknetet das
heißt wir holen ihn jetzt raus er sollte
sich Ruhe er sollte sich schön lösen ich
mache das zu einer schönen Kugel geben
Sie eine große Schüssel und lassen es
für zwei Stunden
Freunde ich habe mir Unterstützung
geholt da Fleisch ist mariniert und der
Spieß steht in unserer Mitte irgendwie
fehlt aber noch was ach guck mal nein
ich glaube wir sind fertig ja steht uns
das wir sind bereit Leute jetzt kann uns
wirklich gar nichts mehr in die Quere
kommen wir haben einige Sachen zu
beachten wir müssen jetzt so schneiden
dass wir möglichst alles auf haben ohne
gleich groß drinnen zu müssen überall
ist die Marinade das ist Frankreich
ich würde sagen so groß darf so ein
Stück sein
wir stecken jetzt mal ein bisschen und
dann sehen wir uns gleich wieder
[Musik]
wir haben ein Spieß gesteckt ich finde
er ist nicht schlecht geworden denn oben
ein bisschen dünner und ein bisschen
breiter so können wir quasi das Gerät
perfekt Nutzen der nämlich unten die
Platte und wir wollen ja das oben das
dicke Teil ist mit dem Endergebnis würde
ich sagen können wir echt zufrieden sein
wir werden sehen wie sich gleich verhält
wenn wir den Grill anmachen aber tolle
ist in einer Stunde da das heißt wir
können uns jetzt dringend wieder ums
Brot 2 Stunden sind vergangen und so
sieht jetzt unser Teig aus herzlich
bestimmt verdoppelt in seiner Größe und
wir warten jetzt dass er rauskommt zack
da haben wir ihn auch schön gelöst ohne
dass ich es eingeölt habe und jetzt
machen wir das Ganze einmal zu einer
Kugel jetzt halt Bieren wir unseren Teig
halt hier noch mal noch mal was wir
jetzt damit machen das gleich wieder mit
der großen Kugel wir Falten den so nach
innen die fertig sind gehen wir sie zum
Ruhen in einen teigbehälter so das
letzte Teig Mädchen ist fertig jetzt
denke ich das Ganze ab für weitere 30
Minuten guten Döner machen neben Brot
und vielleicht noch zwei weitere Zutaten
aus einmal der Salat und einmal die Soße
ich bin hier in NRW hier gibt es
normalerweise keine Berliner Saucen
schöne Kräuter Knoblauchsoße was will
man mehr ein Anteil Joghurt einen Anteil
Mario ab in die Schüssel es folgt die
Joghurt eine Prise Zucker Dillspitzen
und jetzt ganz wichtig geriebener
Knoblauch jetzt gehen wir den geriebenen
Knoblauch mit in unsere Soße sieht nicht
so viel aus im Verhältnis zum Rest aber
so gerieben hat er es auf jeden Fall
wirklich zweimal dreimal so hart noch
ein paar Zutaten es Saft einer halben
Zitrone und ein bisschen fein gehackte
Petersilie dazu eine ordentliche Prise
Salz jetzt nur noch verrühren und fertig
ist unsere Soße oder das sieht so gut
aus wie die Knoblauchsoße die ich so
liebe
boah das hier in Köln zu essen egal ob
wir jetzt zum Salat wir haben einige
Zutaten Zitrone Tomaten Gurke Petersilie
Eisbergsalat und Zucker das jetzt an
[Musik]
wir haben alle Zutaten in unserem Salat
jetzt wird sich das Ganze gibt einen
kleinen Schlucken Liebe Öl dran bisschen
zu mag nicht zu viel davon aber so als
kleine Geheimzutat bisschen Salz aus der
blockbox und Leute ich muss ganz ehrlich
sagen ich habe es gerade noch mal
gemerkt für genau solche Fälle habe ich
die Produkte gemacht man kann einfach
schneller arbeiten effizienter arbeiten
es macht einfach Bock ein bisschen
Eigenwerbung an der Stelle okay werfen
wir jetzt einmal den Salat ein bisschen
durch ich glaube da sollten wir auf
jeden Fall nicht sparen mit Salz mit
Gewürzen jetzt bringen wir den Spieß ein
bisschen in Form und es schneidet sich
wirklich wie Butter hier runter mit dem
originalen dönermesser weil wir kriegen
das natürlich noch ein bisschen Übung
rein aber ich glaube in wenigen Minuten
haben wir hier einen perfekten Spieß
Hängen der bereit ist damit direkt was
zu finden
lassen so einfach mal und mitgewirkt so
zu gucken hat das ist alles andere als
einfach wenn man denkt man kann so diese
diesen Dönermann ersetzen der das 20 30
Jahre gemacht das boah sollte das nicht
so gut funktioniert wie wir hoffen auch
die schneide-maschine
das ist das erste probieren Frau wir
haben einfach Döner gemacht gut schlecht
ihr werdet erfahren Leute machen wir die
Brote fertig bisschen mit Wasser
beschmieren das hilft einfach dass die
Oberfläche nicht so schnell austrocknet
und funktioniert sozusagen als Kleber
für die Körner die wir gleich drauf
geben wir halten es ganz simpel im
Rezept die Hauptzutat ist unsere Liebe
die wir reingesteckt haben 220 Grad ober
Unterhitze
ab und platzieren ist auf dem
vorgewärmten Backblech ganz wichtig so
wird er auch von unten schön knusprig
keine Zeitangabe die Augen regeln lassen
Leute wir gehen jetzt noch einen Topf
mit kochendem Wasser unten hinein das
quasi unsere Döner Brote während des
backen ist mit Feuchtigkeit versorgt
werden
bei denen am Ende noch mal schön mit den
Fingern reingegangen und das macht in
der Optik glaube ich noch mal eins zwei
Punkte aus auf jeden Fall das ist schon
noch mal ein anderer Schnacks es wird
jetzt Zeit für den finalen Döner das
Fleisch zu schneiden wir haben eine
wunderschöne Bräunung und ich gehe jetzt
einfach mal an die Arbeit
soll ich das mal an schönes Dönerfleisch
eine Seite saftig eine Seite knusprig
jetzt nehmen wir das Fleisch rüber
welches nehmen wir welches ist unser
hollebrot ich glaube wir sehen uns alle
oder das fühlt sich auch viel besser an
jetzt als davor gleichmäßig oval mit
Dampf gebacken und danach noch mit einem
feuchten Tuch drüber auch beim
Aufschneiden müssen wir natürlich
aufpassen dass wir nicht zu tief gehen
aber trotzdem den Döner weit genug
öffnen können deswegen gleichmäßig
befüllen ich habe natürlich jahrelang
auf diesem Moment hingearbeitet viele
Döner gegessen nur für den Fall dass ich
mal selbst einen machen würde und so
sieht unsere Dönertasche von innen aus
schön wunderschön
Knoblauchsoße dann zu allererst nach
unten eine Schicht Fleisch am Salat muss
ich nicht geizen wir geben ordentlich
von unserem schönen Gewürzen Salat rein
das noch mal gezogen es gibt nämlich
Saftigkeit noch mal eine Schicht Döner
Fleisch es fühlt sich so geil an den
Döner zu füllen wirklich das ist einfach
ein Kindheitstraum zu guter Letzt legen
wir dann noch ein bisschen Knoblauchsoße
drauf eine Frage bleibt Holle mit scharf
oder ohne scharf
da ist das Ding ab auf den Teller so
Leute das hier ist er also der
selbstgemachte Döner und ich habe den
dönertester Nummer 1 an meiner Seite
Pollen danke
was mir eben schon aufgefallen ist diese
schönen ölige dieses fettige was ihr da
drin sind das ist krank das ist 100 %
selfmade Charakter leicht andere sage
ich mal ja Fleisch dicker als beim
normalen Döner aber rein wenn ich den
Döner jetzt zum Dönerladen kriegt
Feierabend Wunder würde nicht sagen oder
ist aber was anders komisch das sieht
einfach aus wie ein Döner aus dem Laden
darauf stellen und auch so dicke
Fleischer habe ich auch schon bekommen
und das war geil ne das ist einfach mal
ich bin so aufgeregt was zu meinem Döner
sagst
geile Soße für immer richtig Power nicht
an Power Geist das ist auch gut wirklich
aufgeregt wie vorher erwähnt ich habe
schon einige selber gemacht und das ist
echt eine einzige Aufgabe an alle kannst
du ja vielleicht schon der erste Tendenz
abgeben für meine Zuschauer die richtige
volle rolle Bewertung gibt es auf seinem
Channel das ganz wichtig schaut da
vorbei erster Link in der Beschreibung
ich bin gespannt was du sagst also erste
Tendenz auf jeden Fall sehr schön vor
allem dieser das wofür ich auch stehen
was ich gerne bei mir probieren auf dem
Kanal macht es selber geht zum
Dönerladen der irgendwie Liebe
reinstecken
schon mal auf jeden Fall sagen WOW okay
Leute dann probiere ich gleich auch noch
ganz in Ruhe in der ruhigen Ecke Holle
danke für deinen Bewertung danke dir
vorbei und hier in der Kamera geht's
weiter da ist er jetzt also Leute der
selbstgemachte Döner mehrere Tage
arbeite Recherche und vor allem liebe
stecken hier drin tolle ist weg ich
probiere den jetzt ganz in Ruhe für mich
selbst und sag euch wie zufrieden ich
mit meinem Ergebnis bin
[Musik]
boah das erste was mich abholt ist diese
Soße ich glaube das ist das erste Mal
dass ich hier in Köln eine dönersoße
Esse die mich wirklich umhaut wobei das
hat auch eine geile Knoblauchsoße aber
die hier Mama mir die ist nicht von
schlechten Eltern das Brot ihr seht ist
sie verdammt gut aus innen drin schön
fluffig hat eine ordentliche Hefenote
man merkt und schmeckt das ist
selbstgemacht ist frisch aufgeschnitten
ist es sogar noch knusprig die Salat
mischen kommt auch super gut generell
das ist ein rundes Ding ich bin wirklich
wirklich zufrieden mit diesem Döner ich
kann nur sagen es geht wieder mal ein
geiler Tag in der Küche zu neige es ist
immer wieder geil was man Neues machen
kann wir sehen uns beim nächsten Video
wieder bis dahin ciao ciao
[Musik]